who are we asking for permission to do
what we want to do that should be
eradicated so if you are not paying
attention to your intention then your
life just kind of is a bit of a hot mess
you get in the elevator with someone
after an interview and they're just
bitching and moaning or a year.this bad
thing that's happening it's not
happening - it's happening point if your
dream only includes you it's too small
I've been crew so I know how it feels to
be on a set where there's not you know
warmth emanating from behind the camera
I look at you know each year that's
passed and all I've tried to do is
continue to make work favorite thing to
say my mom is treated like you'd like to
be treated she always always says that
the last film that I just I I had in
theaters I distributed myself on 22
screens now it's on 2,300 screens when
you're a creative person and you're
nurturing that within yourself you open
yourself up to a lot of discovery that
comes from unexpected places which is
really wonderful she's an American
director screenwriter film marketer and
film distributor at the 2012 Sundance
Film Festival she won Best Director for
her feature film middle of nowhere she's
the first black female director to be
nominated for Golden Globe Award
she's Ava Duvernay and hear her top ten
rules for success you know we have to
work without permission especially as
women in this industry who are we asking
for permission to do what we want to do
that should be eradicated you need to
set a path and start walking and that is
what I've tried to do and what I try to
encourage folks to do walk with me let
me walk with you let's walk with each
other
I think you know so much of the industry
is very permission-based and once you
get out of your mind that you have to
ask anyone to do what you want to do
you'll be better for it the intention of
our attention it's so big for everyone
but especially for artists and creative
types like us it's the cause that
produces the effect and the effect is
our life so whether you're conscious of
it or not your intention is the cause
that produces the effect which is your
life so if you are not paying attention
to your intention then your life just
kind of is a bit of a hot mess that's
what I found each decision we make an
action we take is borne out of
tenshun so every thought person
experience that we give our attention to
is motivated by intention you've been in
this room before
as a deployer I think before you ya know
I did work they work for Grandma a lot
of work for Paramount when I have my
agency might be our friend but you so
you know what the business side of all
of this is you know what the machinery
of all of this is but you still you
really do seem to have a be having a
great time going through this experience
at this point is that fair I think I
think having done the publicity for so
many years and been a part of that
machine I really would always watch
filmmakers and just wonder they were so
entrenched in it in a way that was they
were missing the joy of it I would see
it you know when you're standing off the
side and you see someone just so bogged
down in press and in numbers and in
deals that they were missing the fact
that they were living their dream you
know truly like they were you know you
get in the elevator with someone after
an interview and they just bitching and
moaning or a year you know that they're
either trying on beautiful dresses but
they're upset because it's you know they
don't get the dresses they wanted or you
know what I mean or they you know
they're sitting at award show but
they're not sitting where the other
person was sitting I just always
remembers like dude you've got to make a
phone like you know what I mean
everyone's talking about it or you know
or everyone's not or whatever but you
you made something you you did it so I
just never want to be that way I really
really don't and I just don't feel that
way I just literally I'm just happy that
I get to make films but one thing she
said to me that really sunk in deep and
really changed my life she said I was
going through a challenge
really tough challenge and she said this
is not happening to you this is
happening for you this bad thing that's
happening is not happening - it's
happening for you you're not the victim
of it you're the beneficiary of it and
to think about anything that's going any
struggle any issue any personal crisis
from the point of view of this is in my
path for a reason changes the dynamic of
the way that you are in the situation
and allows you to see there is going to
be light there somewhere and also it's
not just everything's going to work out
you know what I mean it is challenge
yourself to analyze this moment and
figure out what is really going on that
you know requires the stamina stamina
and a dignity and a presence of mind
that takes you out of the world with me
moment and empowers you
every day I say to myself in some
instance at some level or another this
isn't happening to me it's happening for
me and you know I think back to times
when I was nursing my aunt I'm in the
last days of her life you know with
breast cancer and just being a caregiver
and thinking at that time why is this
happening to us you know to be able to
look back at those hard times and
reassess them from the point of view of
this was an app link to us who was
happening for us I see the beautiful
moments we were able to share the things
we were able to say to each other in her
last days that we had never said before
the gifts that we were able to to give
each other the bonding through
connection through reflection to embrace
cancer and a long dying with as a
blessing in that it wasn't quick and we
were able to say everything we wanted to
say so be able to look at any instance
from a place of Education and
nourishment nourishment as opposed to a
deficit is one of the things that Oprah
taught me and gave me is a huge gift if
your dream only includes you it's too
small if that dream is just about the
thing you want to accomplish and you
don't even know why you want it I mean
it's it's it's too small it may take
your attention but you're not really
winning you may achieve it but you're
not growing from it you're just going
from thing the thing it may look like
success from the outside but if you
don't even truly know how you're doing
it then your cause and effect will be
off and you're not going to be fully
truly living your dreams so I feel a
little weird to tell you that when you
win awards and the light is on you that
it's not going to be enough but that's
what I'm telling you and I wish someone
would have told me that early if we
limit our visions to those things
outside of us to validate us we're
making an intentional error that might
very well bring the outside thing you
want but it'll ring hollow in the end
why because none of that really matters
are you consensus-builder I try I try to
be I mean I really I've been crew so I
know how it feels to be on a set where
there's not you know warmth emanating
from behind
camera when you know crew is kind of you
know just walk past and no one knows
your name and no one really cares what
you're doing even though you're working
damn hard so that's something that also
I just I can't abide like I just I can't
have it so for me I guess with some of
you what you hear or how people might
feel is just because I'm treating them
like human beings you know to be
treating people the way I wanted to be
treated when I was working on these
pictures and working my ass off on these
pictures you know and you know and
sometimes often feeling like you know I
was invisible and so I just try to bear
witness to everyone who's doing anything
on behalf of these movies I find it
quite inspiring
you were in film publicity originally
and then at a certain point you decided
that you wanted to direct can you tell
us how you got from there to here well I
was one of those ladies standing on the
side you know and they they work hard
and no one no one ever really gives them
a shout-out I thank you all the
publicist in the corner you know and as
a person who loved film and wanted to
make film you're standing there
supporting filmmakers telling their
stories and it's something that I love
doing but for me there was always a
little bit of I don't not jealousy but
just like wow that that's great what
they're doing and so at the moment when
I actually started to write and try to
direct my own stuff I was still doing
publicity for other people's films I was
trying to make my own films I was asking
for permission
pitching people trying to get contacts
and Network and do all the things that
don't matter because the only thing that
matters is your work and so when I
finally realized that and started to
make small things and try to move them
around festivals and just you know just
share my work you know the energy behind
matte positive intention started a ball
rolling and I've only been making films
for five years and I only quit my job
full-time three years ago because I was
still holding on to publicity as a
security blanket and so and so yeah you
know I look at you know each year that's
passed and all I've tried to do is
continue to make work whether I have the
money to make a film a narrative a dock
a commercial a TV show
director the episode of scandal a
documentary about Venus Williams
whatever I cast or II I want to tell
through whatever medium short medium TV
medium commercial medium full-length
documentary feature that's something
that I really learn from Spike Lee not
Jones I'm sure Jones is nice I'll talk
to her later she was like Spike Jones is
that no lady it's ugly
um but you know if you remember he did
commercials with Jordan he's done it's
me almost as many dots as he's done
there it is he's made a film every year
for the past 20 years when he's really
the blueprint of just not even a black
filmmaker a filmmaker who's just
continued to make work and so that's
that's how we're here now
favorite thing to say my mom is treated
isn't like you'd like to be treated she
always always says that since I was a
little girl so that was just something
that you know I carry onto my sets with
me carrying into my my corporate life
sort of my personal life you know my
love life you know in my life always
trying to put the person that I'm
relating to ahead of myself in a way
that doesn't diminish me in a way that
actually enlarges me and so that's a
fine balance something that you have to
learn because you can get taken
advantage of but there's a way to do it
where you're actually getting more than
you're giving when you allow another
person to
be first and so that's that's a direct
lesson for my mom you have time to even
think about like where you are in the
award season at this point where or
isn't a good dress for the Golden Globes
and it's two days before that's two days
from now I don't I don't
who's gonna come to your house and give
you a dress please we don't know if
it'll work out okay it always works out
it always works out but no I mean I
think it's only because it was a
publicist before and for whatever
thoughts I used to have about how much
that was waste of time hmm I should be
making films I start too late you know
should have gone to NYU or Howard film
school and learned all this and I should
have you know realized what I wanted to
do earlier I started making films in my
early mid 30s I was a publicist you know
what I mean the odds that that was ever
going to work and I'd ever be sitting
here with you that I'd be here on
opening day today's opening day the last
film that I just I I had in theaters I
distributed myself on 22 screens now
it's on 2,300 screens with Paramount
Pictures who used to be my client like
that that stuff only just puts me in a
place of just being grateful that I got
to make the phone and I continue to be
able to make films so the dresses and
the numbers and then all that stuff is
just less important to me did just need
to talk to creative people about the way
their minds work sometimes it sounds
kind of freaky when you're a creative
person and you're nurturing that within
yourself you open yourself up to a lot
of discovery that comes from unexpected
places which is really wonderful
I mean for me the writing process is
very much about when I have a really
really good idea of what I'm writing I
need to have notes a good outline
thought it through have some dialogue
like really be clear about what I'm
doing and all that comes from being out
in the world my films are low-budget
independent films very specifically
focused around communities of color and
people of color and families of color
and finding the universality and the
specificity of those stories when you're
making a little bit of film with them
for $50,000 or $200,000 there's nowhere
to hide it's just it's people usually
people talking or not talking but you're
on these faces you're on behavior and so
it you really have to be able to
understand that and so that comes from
living being a black woman walking
around it comes from observing people it
comes from asking questions and so I
find that you know I've got to get out
you know and you got to be around people
and in Los Angeles it's such a sprawl
such a huge place in downtown you could
actually rub shoulders with people you
can actually see faces that are not
behind a car window you know what I mean
the best thing is when you see people in
you're wondering what's their story how
do they fit together where they came
from where are they going what's their
connection sometimes I'll even ask and
people want to talk you know and it's
it's it may not be anything that's
directly related to the work that you're
writing that day but that energy from
people that stuff is kind of like you
know seeds on fertile ground that that
helps with the writing for example one
of these great places to kind of just
find a good corner and spot call the
last bookstore I mean it's such a great
space you know that density that I
talked about it seemed in swith books
and people and it's not too busy but
just enough the right flow of the odd
character that comes in and out you know
is part of what I prefer to have around
me when I'm
I'm outlining I'm playing with dialogue
I'm figuring out what the beginning
middle and end of the scene is you know
is it moving the film forward really
trying to pin down those those big
questions I consider movie watching
people watching because you're watching
people you're watching behavior actors
kind of mimic human behavior we're here
at the Downtown independent which is one
of my favorite places to be inspired
it's a great one house movie theater
downtown LA I really love it here I love
coming down and watching other people's
films I live in coming here and watching
my own films wherever I find myself
these spaces that inspire you know they
they it leads to the sparking of my
imagination I definitely am recognizing
when I'm being hit and inspired and and
then making sure that I'm logging that
or documenting that in some way I take
pictures a lot and then yeah I take a
lot of notes and I find that I used to
just scribble on scraps of paper but now
more and more I rely on the phone I'll
put in the subject header XO I don't
know that's my code hugs and kisses to
myself of inspiration it's so corny and
so whenever I'm ready to sit down or I
need to pull in something that I've seen
I just search XO and everything comes up
whether it's a picture or a thought a
lot of my directors work is happening
during the screenwriting process
questions about character and being able
to answer those questions for actors a
lot of that stuff I'm answering for
myself as I'm collecting my material to
write I have a special exercise that I
hold very close to my heart for when I
am in a rough patch
it's called procrastination I will put
it off until something else strikes me I
wish I had a magic talisman to pull me
back into the space I just don't you
know I gotta be in the right headspace
or else you're just forcing it and it
just never comes out right I know there
were times when you know I wasn't
working in a creative way that I felt
very unhappy that I wasn't living my
best life and so for me to be creating
to be around creative people something
that's really necessary for my own
personal happiness and I'm just you know
really fortunate that I get the
opportunity to do it because everyone
that needs that doesn't get the
opportunity to do it and I was one of
those people for a long time so I'm
happy to be in this place thank you so
much for watching I made this video
because Ella Franklin asked me to so it
was a famous entrepreneur that you want
me to profile next leaving the comments
below and I'll see what I can do I'd
also love to know which of the top ten
rules you heard today had the biggest
impact on you leave it in the comments
below I'll join the discussion thank you
so much for watching continue to believe
and I'll see you soon